oui ils vont jour merci beaucoup aidé à
grégoire d'être notre invité politique
ce matin on dit ravi de vous retrouver
sur sur ses plateaux après votre congé
maternité en qui n'est pas un secret on
va d'ailleurs en parler dans quelques
instants vous êtes secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'économie sociale solidaire
et responsable en est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour stéphane bern et
bonjour bonjour de ouest france on
commence bien mais évidemment il ya des
devoirs par l'ukraine puisque vadimir
poutine a donc pris la parole hier à la
télévision il reconnaît l'indépendance
des séparatistes pro-russes il ordonne à
l'armée russe de rentrer dans ces
territoires est ce que quelque part
cette décision de vladimir poutine c'est
l'échec des manuels macro
je crois qu'il faut et je sais que vous
le faites souvent de bon matin ici
raisonner à la hauteur du sujet
emmanuel macron a fait tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient et continuera à le faire
d'ailleurs dans les prochains jours et
depuis des semaines des mois pour
maintenir la paix encore plus depuis que
la france préside l'union européenne il
n'a pas ménagé ses efforts il ne
ménagera pas
on a aujourd'hui besoin de saisir le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu il a réagi
tardivement hier soir par le truchement
d'un communiqué de presse le l'enjeu est
bien plus important et je sais oriane
que vous comprendrez ma réponse que de
savoir si c'est une victoire ou un échec
des manuels macron je ne doute pas que
toute la journée sur les plateaux télé
vont défiler les oppositions sur cet
angle d'un échec du président de la
république de grâce laissons le sujet à
la hauteur et s qui sait pas quand mais
dans la journée sur la volonté de donner
les jours le président de la république
est un homme lucide s'illusionne bas il
a fait tout ce qu'il était dans son sens
au pouvoir de faire il n'a pas dit son
dernier mot il va continuer y portent
aujourd'hui et c'est souvent de
l'extérieur de la france qu'on en parle
le mieux il porte aujourd'hui la voix de
l'europe et pas uniquement de la france
tout le monde l'a compris et c'est au
nom de la présidence française de
l'union européenne qu'il est en première
ligne à la pointe de l'épée pour
préserver la paix en europe il s'agit
rien de moins quand même que ça je pense
que on est tous les trois inquiet je
pense sincèrement en tout cas je sais
pas pour vous mais moi indépendamment de
mon ma petite fille qu'on a tous mal de
remous on a mal dormi parce que ce qui
se passe est très inquiétant et on n'est
pas dans des considérations bassement
électoraliste sur ces enjeux là dans un
communiqué diffusé hier le chef de
l'état a évoqué les sanctions
européennes ciblées il a parlé de
d'individus et de d'entités est ce que
est ce que ces sanctions peuvent aller
jusqu'à bladinières poutine lui-même par
exemple alors je ne vous me connaissez
j'ai pas ma langue dans ma poche je
n'irai pas plus loin que ce que je viens
de vous dire pourquoi parce que je suis
en charge égale me sociale solidaire et
responsable à bercy et que je ne suis
pas ça n'a échappé à personne ni miniser
affaires étrangères ni encore moins à
l'elysée par conséquent je ne
m'aventurerai pas sur le type de
sanctions par prudence et par respect
aussi des négociations diplomatiques
on en saura plus dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochains jours quand
même est-ce qu'à paris si la russie
coupe le robinet de gaz est ce que
finalement les européens vont pas se
retrouver par dans les risques sont
nombreux et c'est pas pour rien que le
président de la république a réagi
depuis des mois il a agi au-delà de
réagir pour éviter la situation
belliqueuse et la guerre
sur les 900 penser qu'au delà des mots
il pourra il pourra vraiment y avoir des
actes est ce que l'union européenne
n'est pas finalement impuissante non
l'union européenne vous savez
et merci d'en parler l'union européenne
elle est puissante elle est capable si
tant est qu'elles soient unis et
aujourd'hui elle est unie derrière celui
qui porte non pas la voix de la france
mais la voix de l'union européenne c'est
emmanuel macron ce qui me frappe
accessoirement c'est qu'on parle souvent
de la faiblesse de l'europe et vous
savez je le dit sur le ton de la blague
mais en vrai ça me fait pas rire du tout
depuis que je suis revenu j'essaye de
dire ce que je fais par exemple en
matière et je sais que ce matin on
pourra d'économie sociale en europe ou
de responsabilisation du capitalisme en
europe à chaque fois que mes
collaborateurs de cabinet parle
présidence française de l'union
européenne
les programmateurs des plateaux nous
dire non madame grégoire pas la paix
chez eux parce que par contre on va
parler de la campagne par contre on m'a
parlé de telles polémiques par contre on
va parler on peut pas être européen les
années bissextiles voyez vous moi je
suis européenne tous les jours ça fait
plusieurs mois et ça va continuer qu'on
dirige la présidence française de
l'union européenne c'est pas tous les
ans que ça se passe merci de me
permettre de pouvoir parler de comment
on promeut des politiques économiques en
europe en ce moment même mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut pas d'un côté ceux s'émouvoir
de la faiblesse de l'europe et d'un
autre côté ne jamais en parler aux
français et à ceux qui la font vivre est
ce que est ce qu'il est ce qu'il faut
qu'il y ait puisqu'on est sur une chaîne
parlementaire ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait
un débat au parlement sur ce sujet
moi je viens du parlement donc je suis
idiot en règle générale a priori
toujours favorable au débat point 1.2 je
rappelle que dans le domaine
diplomatique et notamment le chef des
armées c'est le président de la
république c'est le domaine de
l'exécutif et donc je comprendrais aussi
qu'en fonction de la gravité et de
l'ampleur de la situation des mesures
doivent être prises
concomitamment peut-être un débat mais
le temps du débat peut aussi ralentir le
temps de la diplomatie donc ça doit être
le fruit d'un équilibre et je pense pas
forcément la presse ou par exemple
aujourd'hui et demain il ya un débat sur
la politique française au sahel qui là
aussi la meilleure regrette yves
d'emmanuel mâcon est ce que de la même
doit y avoir un débat sur ce
je vous le redis je suis a priori
favorable au débat parlementaire il ne
faut pas non plus que le temps du débat
est là la situation est chaude pour ne
pas dire brûlante entravent le temps de
la diplomatie en la situation est chaude
pour ne pas dire brûlante je reprends
vos mots ça fait des jours et des
semaines qu'emmanuel macron laisse
planer le doute sur sa candidature en
raison de la crise là on est on est au
plus fort de cette de cette crise est ce
que du coup comment est-ce qu'il peut
entrer en campagne dans de bonnes
conditions maintenant dans les jours qui
viennent
je sais pas ce que veut dire entrer en
campagne dans de bonnes conditions
officialisé sa candidature tous avancent
que c'est un homme le président de la
république et c'est aussi pour ça que je
suis derrière lui quel sens des
priorités je me questionnais avant de
venir ce matin en me disant imaginez
deux secondes que depuis trois quatre
jours cinq jours emmanuel macron soit
candidat et soit dans des meetings sur
les territoires soient circonstances que
donne la norme et je serai là en fait ce
matin et c'est pas à votre encontre que
je dis ça je serai là à défendre le fait
que le président de la république soit
candidat dans un moment de tension telle
que et c'est jean louis bourlanges qu'il
disait hier sur une radio nous n'en
avons pas connue et jean louis
bourlanges sait de quoi il parle depuis
à peu près ce temps la rbi sur les
affaires étrangères même si pardon
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et un homme d'expérience
donc à un moment il faudra bien qu'ils
se déclarent tout me souviens date
butoir ya une date butoir donc ça ça lui
a pas échappé il est international et la
situation lisa grégoire et sera pas
réglé d'ici nom est ce qu'à un moment
vous allez pas vous retrouver à défendre
président de la république en train de
régler une situation internationale
c'est fort possible parce qu'il n'est
pas prévu que la crise s'arrête le 4
mars au matin bien évidemment pour
autant il ya un sujet très important qui
a un impact direct on peut pas trop
détaillée mais sur le pouvoir d'achat
des français aussi et puis elle réelle
vous savez vous avez rappelé que j'avais
une petite fille il ya quelques semaines
moi j'ai accouché à l'hôpital public
j'ai parlé avec celles qui m'ont
accompagné et celles et ceux qui m'ont
accompagné les médecins les infirmières
je suis dans ma circonscription très
souvent dans le 15e
personne ne m'arrête sur le marché par
exemple pour meyer même grégoire madame
grégoire je suis tellement impatiente
quand est ce que le président de la
république rentrer en campagne non on
m'arrête urban grégoire grégoire on n'en
peut plus du prix de l'essence qu'est ce
qui se passe justement agen on m'arrête
sur même grégoire mon mari a une boîte
il trouve pas de salarié embauché il a
un restaurant il a une boucherie n'y
trouve pas de main d'oeuvre qu'est ce
que vous proposez personne et c'est pas
un jeu de jambes que je vous fais là
mais personne ne m'a arrêté dans la
vraie vie des français de tous les jours
je reconnaisse que le président ait
envahi vie puisque vous en parlez on va
plus que ça fonde un problème c'est qu'à
un moment vous même je veux je parle de
la république en marche au des macros et
de la majorité la majorité
présidentielle il faut aussi vous soyez
au clair sur les thèmes sur lesquels
vous allez faire campagne et tant que le
président a donné l'impulsion en
déclarant sa candidature
c'est pas parce que le président n'est
pas officiellement candidat à un moment
où on se parle que la maison ensemble
citoyens majorité présidentielle je ne
travaille pas hier soir j'étais encore
au siège no he marche avec stanislas
guérini edouard philippe françois bayrou
laurent hénart franck riester
l'ensemble des dirigeants de la majorité
présidentielle nous travaillons il ya
des idées qui sont posées il
manque quelque chose encore il manque un
candidat mais on est presque tous en
campagne hivernale et l'énergie et
l'envié et les idées et on va revenir
chez les villiers c'est lesquels
justement quotidien pendant la
présidentielle échappé que je veux pas
les déflorer ce matin oui non mais
pendant la présidentielle il ya eu il ya
eu campagne de la part de la majorité
présidentielle sur ce clivage
mondialistes contre tu devrais la
présidentielle ça va être quoi le thème
de campeurs je ne saurais m'exprimer
sucre sur ce que je ne maîtrise pas le
quasi néant je me met en risque donc il
y aura plusieurs thématiques moi je
travaille ça vous a pas échappé à bercy
donc je fais des propositions en matière
économique il y aura des propositions
évidemment en matière d'éducation en
matière d'environnement en matière de
santé sur les grandes thématiques et
accessoirement intéressent les français
et qui contrairement à ce que certains
sur l'échiquier de l'extrême droite
veulent nous faire croire ne sont pas de
façon obsessionnelle sécurité
délinquance immigration vous le savez
aujourd'hui la préoccupation première
des français c'est pouvoir d'achat je
dirais que ça tombe à point nommé parce
que c'est la préoccupation première de
ce gouvernement depuis 2010 est ensuite
c'est la santé ensuite ce sont les
questions environnementales sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets nous aurons des
propositions et notamment sur le domaine
du pouvoir d'achat alors justement le
pouvoir d'achat cf reste effectivement
la préoccupation numéro un des français
sauf que vous le savez très bien les
prix du carburant continuent à augmenter
il bat encore de nouveaux records est-ce
que vous pouvez continuer à dire que les
mesures prises sont suffisantes et qu'il
ne faut pas en prendre d'autres dans les
dents les jours à wisches de continuer à
dire en tout cas je dirais pas
suffisante elle était absolument
nécessaire il ya eu un travail de fond
déjà depuis 2017 je vais pas aigri mais
l'ensemble des mesures mais quand on
supprime la taxe d'habitation quand on
supprime les cotisations sociales
maladie vieillesse sur les salaires
quand on supprime
5 milliards d'euros d'impôts sur le
revenu tout ça c'est 25 milliards
d'euros qui ont été rendus aux français
et qui leur permettent pour une personne
au smic par exemple d'avoir
effectivement promesses tenues un
treizième mois à la fin du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro promesses tenues selon
l'engagement de la discussion des grands
chiffres effectivement c'est en avril
est un apport mais qu'est ce que la vie
est dure et aux français qui vont faire
leur essence ça c'est du voilier
eux qui permettent c'est important parce
que cette crise et les là aujourd'hui
mais quand la crise se retient rares ces
gains de pouvoir d'achat de meuron il ya
ensuite la conjoncture 15 milliards
d'euros qui ont été mis sur la table par
ce gouvernement pour pouvoir mettre en
place le bouclier tarifaire pour pouvoir
mettre en place le chèque inflation je
sais que on est assez insensible dans
notre pays aux comparaisons mais quand
on regarde ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en espagne en italie en matière de
hausse des prix de l'énergie et quand on
regarde les ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
et ce qui se passe en france on a quand
même sacrément protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français en matière
d'énergie avec le bouclier tarifaire est
suffisant j'ai envie de vous dire pour y
travailler depuis cinq ans que c'est
vous aussi pour ça que je laime sept ans
je sais que ça n'est jamais suffisant
pouvoir d'achat c'est toujours
nécessaire mais c'est jamais suffisant
donc il va falloir qu'on continue est ce
qu'on sera capable d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat ont continué à baisser
les impôts c'est notre objectif le
rapporteur du budget lors encore dit a
pas longtemps peut-être moins que nous
l'avons fait pendant cette première
mandature 50 milliards d'euros rendue
aux entreprises et aux ménages mais on
continuera à le faire et sur les gains
de pouvoir d'achat il ya aussi le sud
est de la rémunération sur lesquels nous
sommes nombreux à travailler il ya le
fixe c'est tout le travail que nous
menons sur les branches on est quand
même dans un pays où vous avez de
nombreuses branches secteur pour parler
simplement qu' aujourd'hui rémunère en
deçà du coût du prix du smic le travail
dans notre pays donc un énorme travail
un peu technique mais sacrément
importants menés par elisabeth bornes
pour faire un saut salariales de branche
par branche domaine par domaine va
aboutir ce travail là il a déjà abouti
on a des filières comme le bois
l'habillement les volailles qui n'avait
pas un salaire minimum au smic qui
aujourd'hui sa ligne sur le smic on a un
peu moins de 40% des branches qui
respecte le salaire minimum c'est dire
qu'ils aient encore 60% des branches
qu'il faut emmener dans la négociation
et ça il faut le faire dès les premiers
mois après l'élection 2022 mais jusque
ça c'est important on y verra suis dit
si emmanuel macron est réélu il y aura
pas d'augmentation d'impôts mais les
baisses d'impôts seront moindres que
dans ce quinquennat qui vient de passer
c'est normal 20 milliards d'euros sur la
taxe d'habitation pour tous les français
on ne peut pas d'un côté nous reprocher
la dette et je ne doute pas qu'on en
parle dans quelques instants et d'un
autre ne pas considérer qu'on soit
sérieux il qu'on agisse avec raison et
pragmatisme ce qui a été fait en matière
de baisses d'impôts dans ce quinquennat
est historique c'est pas pour rien qu'on
retrouve un niveau d'imposition qui
requit relève des années après 2010
c'est à dire qu'on a rattrapés 10 ans
d'augmentation d'impôts avec l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macro et avec les baisses
d'impôts qui ont eu lieu sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés sur la taxe d'habitation
sur l'impôt sur le revenu il y en aura
d'autres mais on sera obligé de faire un
peu moins en revanche nous financerons
la résorption du déficit non déplaise
aux esprits grincheux ni comme nicolas
sarkozy l'a fait ni comme françois
hollande l'a fait c'est à dire que nous
estimons avec la république en marche
contre la méthode du père fouettard
austérité on arrête les investissements
et ont mis en place une politique
d'austérité budgétaire
ça ne crée pas de la croissance ça ne
crée pas de l'emploi on estime aussi qu
augmenter les impôts comme françois
hollande l'a fait ne permet pas de
soutenir la croissance donc nous on a un
parti pris entre le père fouettard et
entre les fous type mélenchon et je pèse
mes mots qui disent on n'a pas besoin de
rembourser la dette c'est de la
pacotille nous on est dans la raison
dans le pragmatisme on crée de la
richesse pour créer des rentrées
fiscales pour permettre de réduire le
déficit public le meilleur remède contre
la dette c'est l'activité c'est créer
des richesses jamais ce pays depuis 15
ans on en a autant créer je sais que on
a beaucoup de sujets graves on a
commencé avec l'ukraine mais tous les
jours c'est des ouvertures de jt pendant
des années où on nous ait dit le chômage
augmente tous les jours on a entendu ça
moi j'ai entendu ça pendant dix ans ce
pays a un taux de chômage que nous
n'avons pas connu depuis à peu près 15
ans 7% 5 4% nous n'avons pas résorber le
chômage des jeunes aussi fort que nous
l'avons fait depuis c'est qu'il ya 4 5
ans pour attendre des niveaux
historiques tout le monde parle et
apprentissage en or nous disons vous
savez les allemands ils sont bien
meilleurs que nous sur l'apprentissage
et entendu ça quinze ans enfin sept cent
mille apprentis enfin lors les
financements qu'on a mis sur la table
bay donc oui à plein de raisons d'être
inquiet oui le pouvoir d'achat il est
directement liée aux prix des lessives
mais ces chiffres sont quand même que
ces chiffres du chômage est ma
croissance qui sont bon là aussi c'est
pas un peu des chiffres en trompe l'oeil
du rattrapage des derniers mois de crise
je sais pas ce que c'est le trompe
l'oeil sur les chiffres j'ai entendu
eric zemmour dire mais les chiffres
c'est aléatoire il ya quelques jours sur
les plateaux mais alors si même les
chiffres deviennent aléatoires je veux
dire bon moi je vous parle ici de
chiffres ils sont partagés à quelques
pourcentages près par l'ensemble des
institutions publiques de l'état se sont
pas des chiffres de propagande
gouvernementale sont des chips et parce
que vous aviez en mai sont des chiffres
partager est ce qu'on arrive je sais pas
ce que l'échec est ce que c'était les
années punk les mois précédents non
l'équipe n'est pas mauvais les mois
précédents je rappelle que depuis 2010
huit jeux siéger à la commission des
finances avant ce pays est la première
zone d'investissement de tous les
investisseurs en europe et ce depuis
avant la crise je rappelle
accessoirement à la droite notamment qui
nous fait des leçons sur la dette que en
2018 nous avons pour la première fois eu
un déficit public que nous avons su
réduire en deux salles et 3% permettant
pas ce qu on oublie aussi de sortir la
france du processus de déficit excessif
et que avant la crise nous avons entre
dit 2017 et 2019 connu un déficit public
en diminution extrêmement fort ça veut
donc dire qu'on est capable et créer de
l'emploi et de faire venir des
investisseurs tout en réduisant la
fiscalité il ya eu un petit truc après
qui s'est appelée et les gilet jaune
mais aussi la crise du coc vide on a
pris nos responsabilités on a investi 72
milliards au moment où je vous parle sur
les 100 milliards du plan de relance
est-ce que ça crée de l'activité oui et
heureusement est-ce que les carnets de
commandes sont pleins oui et
heureusement est ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui le problème inverse du
chômage dommage c'est à dire un problème
de recrutement de compétences pour
répondre à cette tension économique
extrêmement positive oui donc oui
évidemment que le plan de relance à
créer de l'activité
c'était aussi l'objectif
est ce que cette création d'activités
sera suffisante pour éponger les dettes
ou la dégradation des finances publiques
qui a été généré au cours des deux
dernières années
pour des cons tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
en disant il faut 1 2 milliard d'euros
d'économies par an pour établir les
comptes en fin
alors
deux trois choses la cour des comptes
moi j'ai lu j'ai survolé parce que ça
fait 7 192 pages je crois mais j'ai lu
les principales conclusions et j'ai
écouté avec attention son président
chacun est dans son rôle déjà un canton
et on vient de la commission des
finances on est habitué à recevoir le
président de la cour des comptes qui
nous fait état de son de son analyse et
l'analyse la cour des comptes ce sont
toujours des analyses a posteriori
ça n'a échappé à personne
quand vous êtes en marge 2020 que vous
avez une tension incommensurables dans
les hôpitaux que la france est comme les
autres pays d'europe en chaîne dawn
qu'il faut fermer les boutiques il faut
fermer les commerces donc on met en
place le chômage partiel pour que les
gens et leur salaire à la fin du mois et
ses étangs à bercy j'ai pu observer ça
de très près aux côtés de bruno le maire
on est là dans l'action donc nous avons
pris nos mesures a posteriori la cour
des comptes juge ce qui a été fait c'est
son rôle mais mes mains dans l'urgence
que celui imaginé 2
mars 2020 en dix ans là on va pas trop
bouger parce que vous comprenez ils
disent par exemple sur les stations de
ski ce que je les lui le rapport station
de ski on a déclenchée trop vite et trop
d'argent pour les stations de ski mais
allez dire ça et mal ciblée aux abats
bien sûr allez dire ça aujourd'hui à
celles et ceux qui se débattent pour
faire en centres et les stations de ski
sur l'onglet mesrine a causé et je n'ai
juste pas elles jugent pas si
négativement que ça le quoi qu'il en
coûte en revanche adil sûr le problème
de la bête s'est pas uniquement le quoi
qu'il en coûte ce n'est pas uniquement
la crise ya aussi un problème de
réformes structurelles oui
enfin moi aussi je veux bien les à la
cour des comptes et je peux vous décrire
leur apport dans 5 ans 10 ans qui aura
des problèmes de réformes structurelles
change rien messi d'ailleurs on a même
essayé vous rappeler on a essayé la
réforme des retraites on avait un climat
social qui était complexe et peut-être
une réforme comme l'a dit le président à
amender ou à changer pour qu'elles
soient plus acceptable mieux comprises
et donc comme des gens assez pragmatique
bas devant le rejet de l'opinion et le
refus de cette réforme on a repris nos
travaux est ce que ça veut dire qu'on
n'est pas capable de les remettre sur la
table en 2022 si et nous le ferons mais
sur les neuf mineurs vous dites quoi
chacun est dans son rôle on n'a pas
affaire 9 milliards d'économies oui on
va tout faire pour faire ça ne va jamais
en a beaucoup plus que 9 milliards
d'économies en réalité à faire si on
veut remonter le déficit public donc oui
il faut des réformes structurelles
lesquelles ans c'est quoi la priorité la
prime une des priorités c'est évidemment
la réforme des retraites mais quand vous
le dites les formes des retraites pas la
même que celle de 2017 non pas
exactement la même nous la reprendrons
et je laisse au président de la
république et au prochain premier
ministre la possibilité de la détailler
mais où c'est je pense qu'on n'a jamais
réformé ce pays qu autant que toul avons
réformé en cinq ans une des choses qui
me frappe beaucoup et c'est pas pour
avoir un mot comme ça désagréable c'est
à quel point je n'entend aucune
perspective nouvelle ou innovantes de la
part des oppositions j'ai lu est jolie
avec attention le programme des
oppositions que dit par exemple valérie
pécresse il faut accentuer la réforme de
la ligue b d assurance chômage merci
accentuée des réformes que nous avons eu
le courage de mener sur lesquels
d'ailleurs sur tous les plateaux télé
les lr nos gars c'est du sucre sur le
dos il faut faire la réforme des
retraites merci on a essayé de la faire
il faut baisser les yeux travail attaqué
leurs proches ah oui mais enfin il m'a
pas échappé qu'en 2011 elle était à la
manoeuvre et qu'elle n'a pas forcément
réussi spécifiquement donc il ya
plusieurs gouvernements qui ont essayé
de façon très paramétrique de changer
nous on a un courage qui est de changer
le structurel le fond de notre système
et pas uniquement de jouer sur les
durées de cotisation le niveau des
pensions c'est un peu plus impliquer la
repousser clairement l'âge de départ à
la retraite est ce que vous dites on n'y
coupera pas dans le prochain quinquennat
mais ça fera partie des propositions qui
seront certainement sur la table il en
semble aujourd'hui des acteurs
politiques le savent et les français
longtemps de 6 à l'ensemble des
candidats qui disent par exemple qu'il
faut revenir à une retraite à 60 ans oui
ces candidats là pour moi ont des
programmes économiques qui sont un feu
zablit injouable intenable voilà ça a le
mérite d'être la
dernière question après la
présidentielle quel que soit le résultat
est ce que vous serez vous-même à
nouveau candidate aux législatives
oui cette question est plus facile oui
ça a le mérite de la clarté toujours
dans la même circonscription que j'aime
la 12e de paris 15e nord 7e sud et
j'aurai à coeur de promouvoir bien sûr
le bilan du président de la république
mais aussi mon propre bilan la loi pacte
des propositions en matière de
généralisation de la participation mon
travail engagé à charmer au service
d'une économie plus responsables comme
je vais le porter jeudi à bruxelles à
l'europe puisque nous avons sont et
c'est avec force et honneur que j'irai
demander la confiance des électeurs en
juin prochain pour un second mandat
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu nous
voir sur ce plateau de mètres de vous
revoir merci bon
[Musique]